DC Comics also we're the batman company
people Batman remember remember the 5th
of November
rhyming narration which as you will see
will be our own sin next month I know of
no reason why the gunpowder treason
should ever be forgot movie about
British revolution opens with American
actress pretending to be British this is
gonna go over just about as well as
Bridget Jones isn't it
guy Fox looks an awful lot like Jesus
hey wait a second Natalie Portman isn't
my actual girlfriend in this scene you
had a date and lost track of time so
badly that you forgot to leave for it
until after curfew I know women take a
long time to get ready but Jesus hey
dark night dark Street Dark Stranger
better go down this alley I don't know
about the rest of you but I would
probably be pretty liberal with the
pepper spray once too scary dudes
threaten me but a bee is way too nice to
unleash the fury for some reason the
Willy Kitty's got claws that's racist
boss sign up if you're not a sorriest
piece of ass in or London you certainly
played a source the curfew cops are by
default also rapists multiplying
villanies of nature just you know the
movie did take time to show us that Vee
and Evie left at the same time from
their apartments so the timing isn't so
coincidental but London is a huge-ass
place so even if there's a smidge of
coincidence here it's worth sinning
movie opens with a scene where V is
basically Batman protecting innocent
civilians and alleys at night but then
the entire rest of the movie will go to
great lengths to show he's only
motivated by his own selfish
revolutionary agenda and not a Knightly
vigilante protecting the innocent Evie
is in fact the only and as a person he
saves his entire film quite the
coincidence considering how much he
factors into the ending in view a humble
vaudevillian veteran cost vicariously as
both victim and villain movie works
every V word known to man into this
speech except vagina
also antihero arrives and illiterates
annoyingly to authenticate aptitude at
alliteration
four-oh it means that I like God do not
play with dice and do not believe in
coincidence writers almost always write
something like this when it comes to
coincidences like this I promise you
it'll be like nothing you've ever seen
and afterwards you'll return home safely
alright even if you're a crazy person in
a mask all you need to get a girl to go
out with you is confidence this sign
shows curfew begins at 10:30 and Evy
didn't even leave her house for her
supposed to date until 11:00 p.m. what a
stupid human hey or terrified of our
oppressive government and there's a
scary rapey curfew but there's music
playing so let's all go outside I guess
it's a good thing there's a curfew and
only rapists will be killed by this
building's demise there might be other
stray Natalie Portman's walking around
too but they knew about the curfew and
even the fireworks from an exploding
building form into a V this movie has a
vetted today's a 1984 style villain will
be played by John Hurt who actually was
in the movie 1984 back in the year well
I can't remember this is probably not a
coincidence if the screenplay is to be
believed okay so this London Society has
cameras everywhere the government knew
Evie was with V last night they knew she
was captured by fingerman just before
that
why haven't they already traced her
steps all the way back to her apartment
also I guess after V destroyed the
Bailey he walked evey home back through
the dark alleys without running into any
more fingerman and they didn't say
another word to each other you and
Dietrich didn't you yes at 11 p.m. for
some reason lead on the girl you mean
someone took the five minutes necessary
to watch the surveillance cameras I
don't recall ever getting stood up by a
more attractive woman well maybe you
should schedule dates to begin before
curfew huh only eight hours late fellas
gotcha
only eight hours late fellas also how
did they ided from what was obviously
grainy surveillance cam footage without
finding out her job in the process what
kind of Big Brother government is this
also gotcha that employment ID card
clearly says void on it so even though
you're ultimately lucky that she does
actually work there you are a detective
what possible television show that the
uber conservative Chancellor would allow
are these freaking skimpy flamingo
dancer is preparing for the director
said let's put an apple under one of
these monitors so someone looks like
more of an asshole oh now I see why I
took so long for them to find Evie it's
so that they would arrive too late at
our workplace which just so happens to
be under attack by V right now both
hiding spot actually works
London's government in 2020 in whatever
year this is must also have a stake in
jvz televisions also this is odd product
placement right your TVs are in a movie
about a fascist government and in a big
scene they show static
did some other TV company pay to have
JVC TVs in this instead of their own
damn this family loves them some alcohol
there is something terribly wrong with
this country isn't that movie dialogue
doubles as honest assessment of America
and pretty much every country in
existence except Canada they got figured
out cameras this is the exact line that
caused my first college girlfriend to
break up with me oh you were doing that
already damn I feel like this is a
character who should be a lot smarter
than this why isn't he smarter than this
get anyone not wearing a mask out of
here who besides police officers fit
that description are you including the
two people you just unmasked and pointed
people without a mask get to leave why
are they above suspicion does the order
get everyone not wearing masks out of
here include people with masks all 526
cops fall for this also did every single
officer come out with these two guys are
there not any officers still in the room
who can help out also don't all cops
have a pair of handcuffs
why aren't the mask people in handcuffs
what kind of fascist society is this
anyway these cops are all fired
green wire red wire cliche I did it good
job guy who obviously lucked out by way
of screenwriting we were hit before you
even got started so you're saying that
not only is it a pretty huge coincidence
for V to meet evey in the alley in the
first place but also that he just so
happens to attack the television station
where evey works mind you at a time when
she's in the building and ultimately in
the same fuckin hallway
Jesus everybody's still in the exact
same place they were during these
broadcast while she thinking weren't
there cops outside the building didn't
Vinci tell this guy to cover the exits
how did we get out or are they saying
that Fincher told this one dude to cover
all the exits
either way it's simple as she also let's
not forget V had to carry evey out of
this building without anyone seeing him
and basically stroll through London in
broad daylight carrying an unconscious
girl who was hot as fuck director had
obvious disagreement with the prop
master over the definition of enough
books I picked you up and carried you to
the only place I knew you'd be safe yeah
by an intricate series of secret
passageways and tunnels unspoiled by
London's Big Brother camera network I
guess we'll never know
somehow the description of V is a
terrorist is a major detail in cracking
this case
The Girl From Ipanema cliche yes why is
it better or easier for you to cook this
egg toast stuff without your gloves on
you left your mask and everything else
on so seems like the only reason is so
that Evy and the audience can spot your
burns Oh director had another obvious
disagreement with the prop master over
the definition of enough whack-ass drugs
in this medicine cabinet so the elevator
takes him up to the important floor and
lets him off before any security
mechanism requires him to wave a pass
also wait Evy has clearance to some rich
assholes penthouse at the BTN also BTN
didn't feel the need to update their
security so stuff like this couldn't
happen he's done well that's the kind of
shower I call completely pointless
without any eyes or ears on this one
that kind of cars would cut all of them
everywhere around London there are no
more cameras anywhere we can check for
this guy
yeah I can't believe it either the
mailroom chick can waltz up to the voice
of London's apartment anytime she damn
well pleases let me guess she's indeed
or he stolen her ID badge I mean you
believe this man to be a terrorist right
it makes no sense that they just assumed
Evie is in on it
hey what an asshole this is the assholes
alarm clock right here
fake loud ass sword fighting while a hot
girl is sleeping sorry from the Sade's
irony he keeps his TV tuned to the news
so that when the movie ends Evie can
find out about bra throws death mom gets
killed or captured while the child hides
under the bed cliche the highest paid
personal account was a priest paid
almost 200 grand a month 200 grand a
month this YouTube I'm becoming a priest
it was rather my final remittance that I
was interested in my last little joy you
can't have a corrupt priests character
unless he has sickening sexual appetites
they sent a new girl who I'm afraid is a
little older than usual even forgetting
that V somehow figured out this bishops
exact awful clandestine awful underage
awfulness and was able to change the
order this entire plan rides on a to old
Evie passing the test even though the
priest tastes run along under your grace
I love the confessional game tell me o
sins anywhere but here where the heart
is
the Star Wars prequels no strings
attached those Thor movies is this gun
hiding in the Bible inside the bishops
bedroom because he frequently needs to
dispose of underage sex slaves or
because the movie's plot needed also
heat Point Blank misses anyone with a
gun like this carved out in a Bible has
better aim than this I'm sorry but Evie
you're dressed like a china doll hooker
the driver of the van definitely saw you
his loyalty is no in question but mine
is yo mother was Irish wasn't she
that's racist well he expects me to
believe Evie got from the huge church
crime scene all the way to this dude's
house in that fucking outfit without
being noticed he went a mosque for so
long you forget who you were beneath it
do you intimately know someone else that
might describe ya probably not camera
lingers on probably guilty person way
too long oh my god killed them all
number one she no sure she could be that
coroner who started as a botanist and
knew exactly what bees flower was
someone with such mysterious origins
might be my first guess weird she was
just in the last scene kind of came out
of nowhere
Larkhill Detention Center archive
recorded everyone's picture except the
lady doctor because people who compiled
archives have a sense of drama
dr. Diana Stanton change the name of
Delia storage the same initials what a
strange coincidence I should be given
one today there are no coincidences
Delia only the illusion of coincidence
strange those words keep coming up every
time an insane coincidence happens kind
of dare I say convenient he said
meaningless to apologize yeah tell that
to Pete Rose didn't Finch talk to her
during the daytime at her workplace
didn't he immediately get a call from
his partner about the Lark Hill file
didn't they get an answer about Diana
Stanton changing her name like right
after that why is it midnight now also
how does he know that Diana changed her
name does he know people inside the
registry you would do well inspector to
put it out of your mind on follow orders
my first batch of subjects arrived today
previously before we had his Vendetta
November the fifth
Wow how nice for be that his own
personal tragedy happened on the same
day as the Guy Fawkes tragedy giving him
the perfect costume and target date for
his little rebellion movie continues to
lay on the coincidences nice and thick
so much so that in this world
coincidences shouldn't even be
considered weird or out of the ordinary
or something even worth mentioning again
how does this all controlling Chancellor
have no way to track what this inspector
is doing with his time directly after
being told to drop this line of inquiry
but he's got to use a debugging device
to make sure the Chancellor doesn't hear
this conversation but he's been free to
surf whatever the fuck he wants on the
web get out of here a screenwriter
satire oh wait also this is a ridiculous
miscalculation by Dietrich London is on
edge with a terrorist running around
people within the party are getting
killed he's harboring a fugitive in his
house and he thinks the worse that's
gonna happen is he'll need to apologize
why take the risk the Chancellor is
watching this broadcast this is him with
the milk glass so my question is why
does he let the show continue airing any
further past this point is he like well
it's possible this will be flattering to
me so I won't let this play out he does
have control over the airwaves right he
had to come in with bombs and smoke and
knives to get his unapproved video aired
how the hell did Stephen Fry manage to
do it I love this movie but it makes no
goddamn sense sometimes could you be a
PI coincident okay so they're taking him
away it's the middle of the night is
evey really concerned that they're gonna
immediately start searching the house
for other people they don't think are
there or start cataloging the dude's
possessions why is she moving I realized
the plant needs or two but still
wouldn't most people just their pants
and stay put no a new black banks for a
living notices this I'll be damned
they are hanging around looking around
the house but why with flashlights you
have the homeowner subdued turn on the
actual lights man the hell
yeah no her legs are broken and probably
her spine too he will later say he's
doing this for her own good and for some
damn reason she eventually agrees with
him but honestly this is a fucked up
thing to do to a person when you're the
hero of the movie even if you're the bad
guy this is actual torture he basically
brain watches her to believe the way he
wants her to and morally the movie is
absolutely okay with that and I am not
okay with that
her name is Sarah beautiful I think you
want to read it or since though and in
2015 I started my first film assault
offense it didn't make any money because
it was a historical film about scrubbing
laundry wasn't long till I came for me
honestly why did it take them that long
you cut my hair yeah but it looks good
girl
trust me you told me you talked to me he
did now make sure you stop being mad
about it once you cry a bit and it
starts raining main character has
surprise asthma cliche removed oh what a
surprise our main characters in turmoil
and it's raining outside and II crawled
to freedom through 500 yards of smelling
phallus oh wait didn't seem right no you
didn't it's kind of hard to believe that
the worldly Evie didn't know that this
movie existed it was a 2015 and she was
11 when this movie came out but after
losing Best Picture to fifty shades of
gray I guess it was tough to remember
something before you go a super obvious
shrine that you surely would have seen
in your earlier days spent cooped up in
this place I want to kiss your mask but
I feel weird about it face I'm gonna
give it the old college try here for a
second and see if I can manage to feel
sorry for the guy losing the girl he
intentionally tortured yeah no I can't
wolf continues to devastate geez what
would the second civil war be about I'm
gonna get something dumb like an SEC
team losing to a pac-10 team in college
football or a blown call or something or
being a country divided over the new
Taylor Swift album blood incoming
students is omega me Signum Estonia you
me both bow this story about terrorism
at a tube station is actually about
multiculturalism both the left and main
center articles in this paper are
despite their headlines the exact same
multiculturalism article from before and
the far-right article about sprayers
causing damage is actually an article
about the London mathematic Society
80,000 dead and this article is about
cooking rice where does she she left
these place and now it's pretty much
nowhere to go right what the fuck was
this place the BFC supposedly
main or only personal carrier in this
version of England somehow took hundreds
of thousands of parcels on one day all
from the same source without thinking it
was strange or alerting anyone in a
government office terrible alcoholism
and this family was probably saw when
daughter said I learned it from watching
you cool shot but are you really saying
he's taking the time to set up all these
dominoes in his own home just for a cool
logo art project this is the stupidest
waste of Hiro's time since the gross
squirted out a bunch of lighter fluid in
the shape of a bird just so he could
light it and look cool also V apparently
took over dramatic branding lessons from
The Dark Knight she looked at me right
in the eyes didn't recognize me unlikely
i underground I thought they closed this
wall down they did it took nearly 10
years to clear the tracks lay a bit of
my own because in addition to all the
other I've been doing since I burned
down Larkhill
I'm also an amazing railroad engineer
imagine finally getting the first base
with Natalie Portman and there's this
stupid mask in the way you still haven't
kissed her not really even if your
identity is the mask I know he has some
sort of bullet proof thing on anyway but
why aren't these other guys shooting it
right now he rips off the makeshift
bulletproof vest thing from Marty in
Back to the Future 3 who was actually
ripping it off from Clint Eastwood died
beautiful thing
well this is school and all but how did
they coordinate this like did they all
show up here at the exact same time did
one guy leave his house several blocks
ago and that made the rest of them brave
enough to suit up and join him along the
way did be sent instructions with the
masks and robes or did all these people
just get a look at the storyboards prior
to filming movie tries to just gloss
over how 110 pound Evie managed to pick
up 200-pound V and carry him onto the
train but whatever at this point I just
want to see Parliament explode so in
Batman Begins we want a Batman to stop
the train because Ra's al Ghul wanted to
blow up Wayne Enterprises and a corrupt
Gotham in this movie we don't want the
train to stop because we wants to blow
up Parliament and a corrupt London
Batman had shown up in this movie and
told V you have to believe in the people
of London would B be the bad guy chew on
that movie revisionists movies ending
unintentionally inspires the ending of
limas rock did Wes Anderson do this move
Oh a range of dudes head of six men and
take her up behind the chemical shadow
shooter
there's a shortage of perfect breasts in
this world could be a pity to damage
yours
that's what I have to shatter them and
that's all I had to say about that any
leads on finding this guy leads yeah
sure they got four more detectives
working on the case the God is working
in shifts those be lips and hair color
so natural
only your Undertaker knows for sure
ready yes my name is Derrick you do
that's my name
now that's done with it's time to have a
look at your face
my turn
the Yule Ball has been a tradition of
the Triwizard Tournament since its
inception no place your right hand on my
waist
well my waist be sure next meal time to
ask for your free SEP to was--and
Tenniel cupcake in a cup you met me at a
very strange time